Tammy: NOW, JEN PSAKI SIGNING
OFF AS THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY TODAY, ENDING HER
TENURE, AS THE CHIEF SPOKESWOMAN
AND PROPAGANDA WHERE SHE SPEWED
FALSE NARRATIVES AND PLAYED IN
NEVER-ENDING BLAME GAME.
HERE IS A QUICK TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE.
>> WE HAVE NOTICED THIS WEEK
THAT THE GAS PRICES HAVE GONE
UP, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHY.
A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> WIDELY KNOWN, PETER, THERE
WAS A BROAD RANGE OF
DISINFORMATION IN 2020.
>> WHY IS THE ADMINISTRATION
ALLOWING MIGRANTS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS?
>> WELL, I'M NOT SURE THAT IT'S
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
AS INDIVIDUALS COME ACROSS THE
BORDER AND AS THEY ARE ASSESSED
OR WHETHER THEY HAVE ANY
SYMPTOMS, IF THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS
THEY ARE -- THE INTENTION IS FOR
THEM TO BE QUARANTINED.
THEY ARE NOT INTENDED TO BE HERE
FOR A LENGTHY TIME.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> IT WAS CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THEY COULD NOT GET DISHWASHERS,
FURNITURE, TREADMILLS, OTHER
THINGS DELIVERED ON TIME.
>> THE TRAGEDY WHEN THE
TREADMILL GETS DELAYED.
>> I HATE TO DISAPPOINT
CONSERVATIVE TWITTER, BUT I'M
GOING TO CIRCLE BACK.
AS WE OFTEN DO.
Tammy: THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WERE
LOOKING FOR, ALL OF THESE
GENERATIONS.
AND NOW I'M SURE THAT JEN PSAKI
WILL BE AT HOME OR SHE WILL
CONTINUE AT MSNBC, CONTINUING TO
SPIN ENDLESSLY, AND ON MONDAY,
THE NEW PRESS SECRETARY WILL
TAKE OVER THE PODIUM WHERE WE
CAN EXPECT TO HEAR MORE OF THE
SAME EXCUSES BY KARINE
JEAN-PIERRE.
WE HAVE DAVID WEBB AND JOE
CONCHA.
AS I HAVE INTIMATED HERE, A LOT
OF WOMEN AND MEN HAVE WORKED FOR
A COUPLE OF GENERATIONS NOW, TO
GET WOMEN HELP.
NOW WE ARE WATCHING THIS WITH A
WOMAN AT THE HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY, WOMEN WHO
ARE GENERALLY NOW THE PRESS
SECRETARY AND THEY HAVE THROWN
THEIR LOT IN WITH THE LYING
BATCH, AND THEY HAVE JUST
EXTOLLED IT OUT.
IT IS HEARTBREAKING FOR THE
COUNTRY, BUT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
CHANGE IT.
FOR JEN PSAKI, MAYBE A YEAR AND
A HALF, WHAT DO YOU THINK SHE
WILL TRY TO DO, OR WILL SHE
CHANGE IT UP?
>> OH, I THINK IT WILL BE MORE
OF THE SAME, THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WITHOUT PETER DOOCY THERE IS A
FOIL, SHE BECOMES MUCH LESS
INTERESTING.
SHE WAS AT CNN FOR YEARS, I
DON'T REMEMBER HER STANDING OUT
WHERE SHE WAS A GREAT
COMMUNICATOR, WHERE SOMEONE
COULD MAKE A PASSIONATE
ARGUMENT.
SO I DO NOT SEE HER AS BEING A
BIG SUCCESS THAT PEOPLE ARE
PORTRAYING HER TO BE WHEN SHE
GOES TO HER NEXT JOB.
AND I CANNOT REMEMBER ANY PRESS
SECRETARY WHO HAD THAT SORT OF
SELF-CONGRATULATORY FAREWELL TO
A REMARK LIKE THIS ONE THAT
SHE'S HAD OVER THE LAST MONTH.
SOME HAVE SAID, INCLUDING A
FORMER SUNDAY ANCHOR ON THIS
NETWORK THAT SHE WAS ONE OF THE
BEST AND GREATEST PRESS
SECRETARY'S, LIKE, EVER.
IF THAT IS THE CASE, WHY HAS HER
BOSS, JOE BIDEN, AND HIS AGENDA
FAILED SO MUCH, BOTH IN
PRACTICING AND ON A MESSAGING
FRONT.
LET'S LOOK AT THE SCOREBOARD,
SHE IS SUPPOSEDLY THE BRAINCHILD
IN REGARD TO INFLATION THAT HAS
BEEN RISING, HOW IS THE MESSAGE
THAT SHE GAVE RESONATING.
SO WHEN IT'S 6% OF AMERICAN
VOTERS THAT BLAMED VLADIMIR
PUTIN FOR THE CURRENT INFLATION,
IT'S LIKE, WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE.
Tammy: THE PRESS SECRETARY IS
SUPPOSED TO BE SOMEBODY THAT
COMES OUT OF THE MEETING, KNOWS
THE NARRATIVES, THE
CONVERSATIONS, THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, COMING FORWARD,
WITH A BINDER OF INFORMATION,
LIKE WE SAW KAYLEIGH MCENANY TO
ALL THE TIME, ANSWERING THE
DETAILS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
MISSIONS AS WELL AS WHAT WAS
BEING ACCOMPLISHED.
SHE SAID SOMETHING ONE DAY TO
CLARIFY WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID, AND
HE SAID SOMETHING THAT
CONTRADICTS HER.
IT IS LIKE THAT THEY ARE WINGING
IT AND IF SHE CAN JUST -- IT SHE
REALLY A FRONT PERSON OR SHE
SOMEONE THAT LEARNED SOMETHING
IN THIS PROCESS.
>> NEVER FOLLOWED JOE ON MEDIA
ANALOGY.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I WILL DO MY BEST.
DID SHE ACTUALLY READ THE JOB
DESCRIPTION?
LET'S GO AND LOOK AT DANA
PERINO, OTHERS THAT WE KNOW WELL
HERE.
THEIR JOB WAS TO BRING THE
ADMINISTRATION MESSAGE FORWARD.
JEN PSAKI PUT HER MESSAGE
FORWARD AND SHE WAS STILL
PLAYING THE FRONT WOMAN IN THIS,
RATHER THAN THE MESSENGER FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION WHERE SHE
MADE IT UP AND CIRCLE BACK.
AND IT WILL BE NO DIFFERENT,
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A
REPLACEMENT, SOMEBODY LIKE
RACHEL MADDOW, MAYBE THEY WILL
DO SOMETHING, SHE IS GOING FOR
THIS FEDERAL SALARY TO A HIGH
PAYING SALARY, SHE HAS FAILED
UPWARDS AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PAID THE PRICE AND SHE JUST KEEP
CIRCLING BACK AND CIRCLING BACK,
BLAMING IT ON SOMEONE ELSE.
SO SHE DID HER JOB WHICH IS
MESSENGER FOR THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND THAT MESSAGE AT TIMES WAS
INCOHERENT, AND ALL THEY COULD
THINK ABOUT WAS NEW AND CLEVER
CATCHPHRASES TO SEE HOW FAR THEY
COULD EXTEND SOMETHING LIKE THIS
THAT IS THEN TURNED ON THEM.
IT'S A MONUMENTAL FAILURE.
SADLY, THE WORLD IS WATCHING
THIS.
Tammy: NOTHING WILL CHANGE.
THESE ARE WOMEN, JOE, I THINK
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
JOB IS TO PROTECT THE IMAGE THAT
THERE IS A FUNCTIONING WHITE
HOUSE AND THAT IS WHAT IT SEEMS
LIKE SHE HAS BEEN DOING.
WHOEVER IS BEHIND THE PODIUM
THAT THEY CAN GET TO DO IT, THAT
IS GOING TO BE THERE JOB, SO
EFFECTIVELY THEY SAID THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE A NEW SHOW AND WHICH
HAS NOT DONE WELL.
DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO
TRANSLATE?
DO YOU THINK THAT DEMOCRATS WILL
WATCH THIS BECAUSE SHE WORKED
FOR JOE BIDEN YOU THINK THAT
IT'S BECAUSE SHE'S FAMOUS?
DO YOU THINK THAT SHE WILL FAIL
AT THIS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK HER FUTURE
WILL END UP BEING?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SURE,
TAMMY, THAT THERE IS MUCH OF A
BASE FOR THIS BRAND OVERALL FOR
JOE BIDEN.
WHEN YOU ARE AT 33% APPROVAL.
WHEN YOU ARE AT THESE NIXON KIND
OF NUMBERS, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY OR
INFLATION WHERE THE BORDER, I DO
NOT SEE THAT AS BEING SOMETHING
THE TRANSFERS BECAUSE THERE IS
NOT MUCH OF A BASE TO BEGIN
WITH.
AND AGAIN, JEN PSAKI WAS THE
SPOKESPERSON OF JOE BIDEN.
SHE REALLY GOING TO THE HALL OF
FAME AT THIS POINT CONSIDERING
HOW LOW THE NUMBERS ARE AND HOW
THE MESSAGE HAS SO BADLY GONE?
>> IT IS THE LACK OF EMPATHY,
THAT THIS IS WHAT THEY SEEM TO
ALL SHARE.
YOU KNOW, JOE, HER COMMENT ABOUT
THE TREADMILL, THE THING ABOUT
CALLING A DOCTOR, YOU KNOW, YOU
ARE SUPPOSED TO NOT RUIN OUR
LIVES BUT TO MAKE IT BETTER.
WITH HER REACTION, HER
REACTIONS, IT IS TO MOCK AND TO
RIDICULE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING IN THIS COUNTRY.
AM I GOING TOO FAR IN DESCRIBING
HER ATTITUDE?
>> NO, I MEAN, THIS IS THE SAME
PRESS SECRETARY THAT INSISTED
SKYROCKETING CRIME, POLICE
OFFICERS BEING TARGETED IN THIS
COUNTRY, IT IS ONLY A FOX NEWS
TALKING POINT.
AND WHY NOT GO TO NEW YORK,
PHILADELPHIA, LOS ANGELES, THE
RECORD MURDER RATES THERE, IT'S
A TALKING POINT OF THIS NETWORK.
AND SO YES, SHE IS PATENTLY
CONDESCENDING, THAT WILL NOT BE
WELL ON TELEVISION.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR NEW JOB,
YOU'VE HAD IT FOR A MONTH AND A
HALF ANYWAY AND YOU SHOULD'VE
RESIGNED EIGHT WEEKS AGO, BUT
SHE DID NOT.
>> TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
OWN AND WE WILL SEE WHAT THAT
BRINGS THEM.
IN THE MEANTIME THE REST O